during World War One the federal
government brought over 2 000
prosecutions against individuals for
speech detrimental to the war effort
my students are often surprised to learn
that at this point in our constitutional
history there was not robust protection
of free speech
today we think of the First Amendment as
Central to our constitutional identity
but as late as the early 20th century
constitutional Doctrine related to both
free speech and the religion Clauses was
in its infancy
we'll take a look at the religion
Clauses in subsequent lectures and this
one we'll take a look at early Free
Speech Doctrine
to understand the legal context of these
World War One speech cases let's briefly
look at a few ways in which Free Speech
was not protected during our earlier
constitutional history
John Adams became the second President
of the United States in 1797 just as
political tensions between the
Federalists and Democratic Republicans
were escalating over foreign policy
issues
Thomas Jefferson and other Democratic
Republicans favored friendship with
France believing that the French
Revolution extended the American
revolution's promise of Liberty to
Europe
Federalists took away a different lesson
they saw the reign of terror that
followed the French Revolution and noted
that democracy could Veer easily into
Anarchy
following George Washington's example
Federalists wanted to maintain American
neutrality and stay out of Europe's
conflicts
the parties also disagreed on important
domestic matters as we saw back in
lecture six the Federalists believed in
a strong central government whereas the
Democratic Republicans believed more in
decentralized power
another major difference was their
attitudes towards the people
whereas the Federalists were generally
speaking elitists who thought a muscular
federal government could help secure the
revolution's blessings the Democratic
Republicans believed in popular
democracy and worried that too much
centralized power would lead to
governmental tyranny
these attitudes shaped both parties
reactions to the newspapers of the day
late 18th century newspapers could be as
vicious and unscrupulous as some of our
media and Democratic Republican
newspapers were merciless in their
attacks on President Adams and other
Federalist leaders
some of these attacks were blatant lies
and Adams believed correctly that his
own vice president Thomas Jefferson was
behind some of them
the Federalists saw these attacks as
more than annoyances
they believed that the common man was
easily manipulated and worried that
libelist newspaper attacks on the
Federalist leadership would lead the
country down the road to chaos
just like many today complain about
disinformation President Adams moaned
that the Jeffersonian press would go to
all lengths of profligacy falsehood and
malignity in defaming our government
to respond to these dangers Federalists
in Congress proposed the Alien and
Sedition Acts of 1798.
we'll focus on the Sedition Act which
permitted the criminal prosecution of
any person who writes or utters
any false scandalous and malicious
writing against the government or either
House of the Congress or the president
of the United States with intent to
defame or to bring them into contempt or
disrepute
The Proposal prompted great debates
which broke down along party lines
Democratic Republican opponents of the
bill argued that it violated the First
Amendment which provided that Congress
shall make no law abridging the freedom
of speech or of the press
surely a law that punished a person for
criticizing the government ran afoul of
that Amendment
moreover Democratic Republicans
contended that Federalists wanted the
law to serve improper partisan ends
Pennsylvania Congressman Albert Gallatin
argued that the law represented the
Federalists unconstitutional effort to
perpetuate their Authority
Federalists responded that the law was
necessary to preserve stability and even
the country itself
Massachusetts representative Harrison
gray Otis explained that a government
necessarily has the power to preserve
and defend itself against injuries and
outrages which endanger its existence
Federalists also argued that the
Democratic Republicans overread the
First Amendment
in England a common law freedom of
speech was understood only to extend to
previous restraints that is a protected
against laws requiring a publication to
receive governmental permission before
speaking
Federalists argued that freedom of
speech under English common law did not
protect speakers from punishment after
their speech
James Madison responded that the
Federalists were making an absurd
distinction what good is freedom of
speech if it still permits the
government to punish a publisher after
the fact
Madison argued
it would seem a mockery to say that no
law should be passed preventing
Publications from being made but that
laws might be passed for punishing them
in case they should be made
medicines rejoinder is powerful but the
Federalists controlled Congress and in
1798 they passed the law anyway
contrary to some reports President John
Adams wasn't enthusiastic about the law
nevertheless he did sign it into law a
lapse of judgment That clouds his
reputation still today
anxious to strike back at political
opponents who had attacked them the
Adams Administration arrested about 25
prominent Democratic Republicans under
the ACT including a democratic
Republican congressman who would accuse
president Adams of
an unbounded thirst for ridiculous pomp
foolish adulation and selfish avarice
15 of those cases resulted in
indictments and 10 resulted in
convictions
in addition to democratic Republican
politicians those convicted also
included prominent Jeffersonian
journalists who had also attacked Adams
in his political allies
Thomas Jefferson called the era the
reign of witches
the constitutionality of the Sedition
Act never reached the U.S Supreme Court
but lower federal courts all upheld them
and sentenced to several Democratic
Republicans to prison
from my perspective the history of the
Sedition Act could be read as permitting
the prosecution of the government's
critics
constitutional history though is not
written by judges alone and the broader
historical record repudiates the
Sedition Act
indeed the ACT played a substantial role
in Adam's defeat
Democratic Republicans have used this
Edition Act and the partisan
prosecutions of Adam's political
opponents to help them win the election
of 1800.
the Sedition Act by its own terms
expired in March 1801 the last day of
John Adams presidency
the Jefferson Administration did not
revive the law
decades later in 1840 Congress repaid
the fines that had been levied under the
ACT
an accompanying Congressional report
said that the Sedition Act had been
passed under a mistaken exercise of
power and that it was now conclusively
settled that the Act was
unconstitutional
even though no court had ever said so
as the legal scholar Jeffrey Stone
explains the key lesson from the
Sedition Act then is that the protection
of Freedom rests ultimately with the
people themselves
nevertheless though the public seems to
have Vindicated freedom of speech in its
rejection of the Sedition Act Free
Speech hardly flourished in the century
meeting up to World War One
we've already seen that the Antebellum
South successfully censored abolitionist
speech the prohibition of anti-slavery
speech seems like a blatant First
Amendment violation but those laws
nevertheless remained in place for years
Free Speech also went largely
unprotected in the late 19th century
as we saw in our last lecture
industrialization created among other
things great economic inequality and
dangerous working conditions
tensions between labor and management
escalated
while the progressive and populist
movements gained significant traction
some workers embraced more radical
political agendas like Marxism or
anarchism
by the 1880s radical labor organizations
were advocating violence to disrupt
existing economic and social systems
these movements in turn prompted a
backlash directed against not only
Marxist radicals but also the labor
movement more generally
Mass strikes and labor demonstrations
occurred some violence such as the
Haymarket riot in Chicago in 1886 and
the Nationwide Pullman Strike in 1894.
in 1901 President William McKinley was
assassinated by a deranged anarchist
partially in response to this violence
and unrest the government's sometimes
prosecuted persons for propagating views
it deemed too radical
including feminists pacifists anarchists
labor activists and especially
socialists
when the criminal defendants argued that
they had merely engaged in
constitutionally protected speech courts
usually either Dodge the First Amendment
issues or rejected Free Speech arguments
altogether
for example during the Haymarket Square
labor demonstration in 1886 an unknown
person through a bomb at police
several police officers and civilians
were killed
the government prosecuted persons who
had been advocating Anarchist Doctrine
even though it was not clear that the
speakers were connected to the bomber
and some of the anarchist defendants had
not even been at the rally
the U.S Supreme Court brushed aside the
defendant's argument that their
prosecutions violated their freedom of
speech
some of the speakers were hung
executed essentially for unpopular
speech
in another case the Supreme Court found
no problem with the deportation of a
British citizen because he gave a
lecture advocating Anarchist principles
and contending that people should
emancipate themselves
state courts also usually rejected Free
Speech arguments
it's against this legal background that
Free Speech cases started arising during
World War One in June 1917 two months
after the U.S entered the war against
Germany Congress passed the Espionage
Act among other things the ACT
prohibited speech that incited military
insubordination or the refusal to serve
in the armed forces
the next year Congress passed amendments
to the ACT criminalizing speech with the
intent to cause scorn for the U.S
government to stop the production of War
materials to obstruct the sale of war
bonds or to utter any words supporting a
country at war with the U.S
these laws of course reflected
congress's desire to protect the
country's War efforts
they also reflected congress's efforts
to stifle what it believed were Radical
political and labor movements such as
socialism and anarchism
which still played a prominent role in
the country
labor unrest had continued into the 20th
century with the rise of groups such as
the industrial workers of the world
commonly known as The wobblies Who
announced that the struggle must go on
until the workers of the world organized
as a class take possession of the earth
and Machines of production and abolish
the wage system
the government pursued cases under the
Espionage Act vigorously
a famous example involved NASA's
publishing company which published the
masses a monthly political magazine that
described itself as revolutionary Frank
arrogant impertinent
the masses editor-in-chief was Max
Eastman who called himself the American
lyrical socialist a child of Walt
Whitman reared by Karl Marx
in 1917 the postmaster of New York City
informed the masses that the U.S mail
service would not distribute their
magazine
the Espionage Act included a
non-mailability provision that gave
broad authority to the post office
Department to exclude treasonable
materials from the mail
the postmaster had decided the masses
qualified as non-mailable
the masses sued
the case went before judge Learned Hand
a federal trial court judge in New York
and initially the masses won
as we've already seen Free Speech claims
usually lost in the courts but judge
hand granted the masses a preliminary
injunction against the government
effectively telling the postmaster he
had to continue shipping the magazine
hand did not actually decide the case
technically on First Amendment grounds
instead he construed the Espionage Act
so as to deny the postmaster the
authority to deem non-mailable the
magazine at issue in this case
nevertheless though he decided the case
on statutory rather than constitutional
grounds Han's opinion emphasized the
importance of freedom of speech in a
democracy
for example the Espionage Act gave the
government during wartime the authority
to censor a willfully false statement
judge hand held that the ACT did not
cover any of the material in the masses
magazine which is hand put it was within
the range of opinion and criticism
an opinion may be unpopular hand implied
but that is not the same thing as a
false statement
as a result hand believed the ACT did
not actually reach the material in
question
in another section of the opinion judge
hand addressed the government's effort
to censor material that it claimed
caused insubordination disloyalty Mutiny
or refusal of Duty in the armed forces
hand did not believe the relevant
portions of the masses had caused such
outcomes
criticism of a war is not the same thing
as causing troops to Mutiny or causing
civilians to dodge the draft
the government's aggressive reading of
the law had contended would allow the
suppression of all hostile criticism
this result would be untenable
democratic governments after all depend
on disagreement including disagreement
with the current Administration
and did acknowledge that the government
has some power to protect itself from
speech that threatens its very existence
hand however distinguished between
speech that criticizes existing policy
on the one hand and speech that is a
direct incitement of violent resistance
on the other
political agitation as he put it is a
safeguard of free government
political dissent then is
constitutionally protected speech
incitements to violently overthrow the
government by contrast can be punished
learn enhance insistence that
prosecutors even in times of War
could not go after a speaker simply for
criticizing the government was a bold
defense of free speech
it also fell on largely deaf ears
the court of appeals overturned Han's
opinion and lifted the injunction
as a result the post office could stop
the mailing of the masses
not long after the publication went out
of business
Learned Hand himself suffered some
repercussions too
hand was widely acknowledged as a star
of the lower Federal bench and many
considered him the leading candidate for
an open seat on the U.S court of appeals
for the second circuit the same court
that had reversed hands NASA's decision
hand did not get the promotion then
though several years later he would
had believed in some legal historians
agree that he was initially passed over
because his decision in the masses case
had ruffled too many feathers
indeed learned hands Progressive views
on freedom of speech were out of step
with most jurists of the day
in early 1919 a year and a half after
the masses case a tree with cases
arrived at the U.S Supreme Court
involving criminal convictions under the
Espionage Act
in each case the criminal defendants
asserted that their speech should be
constitutionally protected
in one case shank the United States
the defendants had been convicted of
obstructing military recruitment by
Distributing a flyer opposing the draft
one side said do not submit to
intimidation
the other side was headed assert your
rights it denied the power to send
citizens away to war and foreign lands
and asserted that if you do not assert
and support your rights you are helping
to deny or disparage rights which it is
the solemn duty of all citizens and
residents of the United States to retain
the second case for work B United States
involved a news reporter critical of the
U.S war policy
he was convicted of attempting to cause
disloyalty Mutiny and refusal of Duty in
the military
the third case Debs V United States was
probably the most extraordinary because
it involved a prominent political figure
Eugene Dabbs was the leader of the
Socialist Party and a frequent
presidential candidate
though Debs never really had a real
chance of winning the presidency he was
far from a fringe figure he was well
known throughout the country and in 1912
his presidential campaign had won about
six percent of the popular vote
ever since fighting had begun in Europe
dabs had argued against American
involvement in the war
in 1918 Debs gave a speech that attacked
capitalism and praised socialism
though debs's speech had not explicitly
instructed his audience to obstruct the
draft he had praised three members of
his party who were serving time for
their opposition to the draft
a zealous prosecutor went after Debs for
the speech and the jury convicted Debs
for violations of the Espionage Act
the U.S Supreme Court upheld all three
convictions
Justice Oliver Wendell Holmes's opinion
in the shank case explained the Court's
reasoning most fully
perhaps the same flyer would have been
acceptable in ordinary times Holmes
explained
but when a nation is at War many things
that might be said in time of Peace are
such a hindrance to its effort that
their utterance will not be endured so
long as men fight and that no court
could regard them as protected by any
constitutional right
incidentally by 1919 the fighting in
Europe had ended but the speech had
occurred during the war
that context mattered the question
Holmes said was whether the words given
the circumstances created a clear and
present danger
as Holmes put it in the opinions most
famous sentence
the most stringent protection of free
speech would not protect a man in
falsely shouting fire in a theater and
causing a panic
Holmes's views were typical of his
fellow jurists in fact in all three
cases the justices unanimously affirmed
the Espionage Act convictions and
brushed aside Free Speech concerns
as it turned out though Holmes himself
would eventually have second thoughts
the previous summer in June 1918 Holmes
had been on a train heading to a summer
home on the Massachusetts North Shore
Holmes had been sitting with his wife
but he got up to stretch his legs and
ran into an acquaintance
judge learned at hand the author of the
trial Court's masses opinion
hand was very well respected but Holmes
was three decades older and probably the
most prominent judge in the country
hand was nervous and the famous judge's
presence but he gathered the courage to
raise the topic of free speech
he apparently did not persuade Holmes
because a few days later he wrote Holmes
a letter Beginning by saying that he had
given up rather more easily than I now
feel disposed
had proceeded to explain in his letter
that Society should be tolerant of
dissenting views because we can never be
certain in any debate that we are
correct
if it turns out that the dissenters are
correct and the majority suppresses
their views then Society loses the
benefits of the dissenter's wisdom
Holmes was famously skeptical that there
was such a thing as objective truth and
Hans argument that we can never be
certain that we are correct was likely
crafted with his older colleague
skepticism in mind
Holmes loved intellectual sparring and
enthusiastically replied to Han's letter
but he remained unconvinced by Han's
arguments
Holmes argued that the majority has a
natural right to silence the other
fellow when he disagrees
he alluded to an earlier Supreme Court
case holding that an individual does not
have a right to opt out of a
governmentally mandated vaccination
campaign
Holmes generally believed that in a
democracy the majority can craft
whatever laws it chooses
free speech he wrote to hand stands no
differently than freedom from
vaccination
the two men continued to correspond but
Holmes's views on Free Speech appeared
unmoved
when the Supreme Court in early 1919
released its opinions and shank for work
and Debs judge learn at hand must have
grieved
not only had every Justice rejected the
free speech claim in each case but
Holmes himself had penned each opinion
despite his best efforts judge hand had
failed to persuade Justice Holmes
after the Deb's decision though hand
tried again writing to Holmes to suggest
that instead of Permitting the
conviction of a man because a judge
deemed it likely that his speech will
obstruct the draft a judge should
instead focus on what the speaker has
actually said
hand didn't say so in his letter but it
wasn't clear that Debs had instructed
his followers to obstruct the draft
and also seemed worried about leaving
such cases up to juries since juries
likely will have the same prejudices as
the majority that enacted laws like the
Espionage Act in the first place
freedom of speech hand implied had to
accomplish something more than that
Hans new letter apparently didn't have
an immediate impact on Holmes who was
very busy
Hovis was brilliant but his reply
suggests that he hadn't taken the time
to think through hands ideas carefully
but hand wasn't the only important legal
thinker dismayed by the Court's failure
to protect free speech
Ernst freund a prominent law professor
at the University of Chicago published
an article criticizing the Court's
decision in the Deb's case
freund wrote
to be permitted to agitate at your own
Peril subject to a jury's guessing at
motive tendency and possible effect
makes the right of free speech a
precarious gift
Holmes had an active mind and some
Scholars believed that these and related
criticisms prompted him to reconsider
his views
in late 1919 another Free Speech case
arrived at the court Abrams V United
States
a group of Russian immigrants who were
sympathetic to the recent Bolshevik
Revolution in their home country had
distributed circulars in New York City
opposing what they perceived to be the
U.S government's efforts to crush the
revolution
the Russians advocated a general strike
and appeal to workers in ammunition
factories to stop producing weapons that
might be used against the Russian
revolutionaries
the U.S government charged the Russians
with violating provisions of the
Espionage Act prohibiting speech that
advocated halting the production of
ammunition necessary to prosecute the
war
the defendants were convicted but
eventually took their case to the U.S
Supreme Court arguing that the
convictions violated their free speech
rights
once again as in shank frowwork and Debs
the court upheld the convictions thus
rejecting the Free Speech claims
however this time Justice Holmes joined
by Justice Louis Brandeis dissented
in Abrams Holmes seem to adopt hands
view that the government should be
forced to prove more than merely the
fact that this speech might produce
unwanted Behavior
it should not be enough Holmes argued
that speech has a bad tendency to incite
illegal activity
rather the test should be whether there
is a present danger of immediate evil
this immediacy requirement protects more
speech because it is difficult for
prosecutors to prove that a speech will
bring about immediate harm
Holmes concluded his dissent with a
stirring defense of free speech
the paragraph begins curiously by
offering an argument that seems to favor
censorship
Holmes lays out this argument but then
pivots and explains why Society should
protect even distasteful speech
this passage is so great and so famous
I'm going to read a significant excerpt
Holmes wrote
persecution for the expression of
opinions seems to me perfectly logical
if you have no doubt of your promises or
your power and want a certain result
with all your heart you naturally
express your wishes in law and sweep
away all opposition
to allow opposition by speech seems to
indicate that you think the speech
impotent as when a man says that he has
squared the circle
or that you do not care wholeheartedly
for the result
or that you doubt either your power or
your premises
but when men have realized that time has
upset many fighting figs they may come
to believe even more than they believe
the very foundations of their own
conduct that the ultimate good desired
is better reached by free trade in ideas
that the best test of Truth is the power
of the thought to get itself accepted in
the competition of the market
and that truth is the only ground upon
which their wishes safely can be carried
out
that at any rate is the theory of our
constitution
it is an experiment as all life is an
experiment
every year if not every day we have to
wager our Salvation upon some prophecy
based upon imperfect knowledge
while that experiment is part of our
system
I think that we should be eternally
Vigilant against attempts to check the
expression of opinions that we loathe
and believed to be fraught with death
unless they so imminently threaten
immediate interference with the lawful
and pressing purposes of the law
that an immediate check is required to
save the country
its natural Holmes tells us to want to
silence one's opponents
but we can never be sure we are right
and if Society does not permit a free
exchange of ideas
will never have the chance to weigh
ideas against each other
only through the free trade and ideas
can we know which ideas are the best
Holmes's dissent is one of the most
famous opinions in Supreme Court history
it demonstrates how a Justice even a
brilliant one can change his mind in
just a few short months
more importantly The Descent paved the
way for future Supreme Court decisions
that protected speech
today free speech is a core
constitutional value it's one of the few
constitutional issues that liberals and
conservatives often agree upon
of course free speech is not an absolute
right because no right is absolute
there are cases when the government can
punish speech
such as immediate incitements to
violence or true threats or child
pornography
most people agree that speech of this
sort should not be tolerated because the
harms it brings about are so great
and there are cases where Society still
debates whether government should be
permitted to punish speech
such as disinformation that can erode
our democracy
with just a handful of exceptions though
the court today protects Free Speech
vigorously
and we can trace that doctrine's roots
to Justice Oliver Wendell Holmes's
dissent in Abrams
and perhaps even his fortuitous meeting
on a train with judge learn at hand
one lesson of this story is the
Constitutional Provisions can take on
new meaning in New Times
Americans today think of freedom of
speech as foundational
but it has played a significant role in
Supreme Court Doctrine for less than a
century
another observation is that the ultimate
Vindication of free speech helped lead
to other important constitutional
changes
protest movements on a wide range of
issues
civil rights women's rights gay rights
gun rights all relied on the country's
Free Speech protections to make their
points vigorously
those movements in various ways helped
reshape the country's constitutional
commitments
speech thus is truly a core right
it is a right that helps protect other
rights